hey everyone welcome back to yet another
video by simply learn today we will
explore the facts and Trace passwords in
the it sector the cloud computing setup
bytes of real-time data brilliant
processing speeds securing your data
with the Best in Class 5 volts and much
more we shall jump into more details but
first let's understand the agenda for
today's discussion first we will get
started by understanding what exactly is
cloud computing later we will understand
the critical roles in cloud computing
then the important topic of today's
session that is salaries for different
roles in cloud computing and finally how
simply learn can help you to get the
professional certificates in cloud
computing but before we get started let
me ask you a quick question you can
leave your answers in the comment
section below what is the main benefit
of using virtual machines in cloud
computing the options are increased
Network bandwidth improved scalability
and flexibility enhanced data security
reduce power consumption take your time
pause the video think and answer let me
know your answer when you're ready in
the comment section below alright so now
let's begin with our first topic what is
cloud computing cloud computing refers
to delivering on-demand Computing
resources over the Internet including
servers storage databases software and
other services it involves providing
these service providers who maintain and
manage the underlying infrastructure in
a technical sense cloud computing is
based on distributed network of remote
servers often called as the cloud we
should connect three together as a
single system users can access and
utilize these resources on a pay as you
go basis scaling them up or down as
needed this eliminates the need for
users to invest in and maintain their
own physical infrastructure as the cloud
service provider takes care of the
hardware software and infrastructure
management cloud computing offers
various benefits including flexible
ability scalability and cost efficiency
it enables users to access their
applications and data from anywhere
using any device with an internet
connection the underlying infrastructure
of the cloud ensures High availability
reliability and security having
discussed about the cloud computing
overview and its technicalities let's
move on to the scope of cloud computing
the cloud computing Market has
experienced significant growth over the
past decade and it is projected to
continue expanding in the coming years
according to the market research reports
the global cloud computing Market has
valued around 371 billion dollars in
2020 and this Market size includes
infrastructure as service that is iaas
platformer service that is passed and
software as service offerings the market
is expected to continue its growth
trajectory in coming years according to
the forecast the global cloud computing
Market is projected to reach
approximately 1 trillion dollars by 2020
E6 now proceeding ahead let's discuss
some critical roles in cloud computing
domain first we have the cloud computing
architect a cloud computing architect is
responsible for Designing and
implementing Cloud infrastructure
solutions they analyze business
requirements select appropriate cloud
services and Technologies and design
suitable and secure Cloud architectures
that meet the organization's needs the
average salary of a cloud architect in
India is 26 lakh rupees per annum and in
the United States of America the
salaries range from 100
000 US dollars to 125 000 US dollars per
annual the second one on the list is
cloud engineer Cloud Engineers Implement
and deploy and maintain Cloud
infrastructure and services they
configure and manage virtual machines
storage networks and other Cloud
resources they also automate process
ensure security and monitor performance
to optimize Cloud environments the
average salary of a cloud engineer in
India is 18 lakhs per annum and in the
United States of America the salaries
range from 100 and 40 000 US dollars to
250 000 US dollars per annum the third
one on the list is the cloud developer
Cloud developers focus on developing and
deploying applications specifically for
cloud environments they utilize Cloud
platforms and services to build scalable
and resilient applications leveraging
Technologies such as serverless
Computing containers and microservices
architectures the average salary of a
cloud developer in India is 25 lakhs per
annum and in the United States of
America the salaries range from 90 000
to 120 000 per annum next Cloud security
engineer Cloud security Engineers
specialize in ensuring the security and
compliance of cloud-based systems they
design and Implement security controls
monitor for vulnerabilities and threats
and respond to security incidents they
also work on data protection access
management and compliance framework
specific to Cloud environments the
average salary of a cloud security
engineer in India is 23 lakhs per annum
and in United States of America the
salary range from 80 000 US dollars to
115 000 US dollars per annum proceeding
ahead we have the cloud operations
manager Cloud operations managers
oversee the day-to-day management and
optimization of cloud infrastructure and
services they monitor performance manage
costs and ensure the availability and
reliability of cloud resources they also
coordinate with different teams to
resolve issues plan capacity and
Implement best practices the average
salary of cloud operations manager in
India is 38 lakhs per annum and in the
United States of America it is about 130
000 to 190 000 for annum based on
experience next is cloud consultant
Cloud Consultants provide strategic
guidance to organizations in adapting
and optimizing cloud computing solutions
they access business requirements
recommend Cloud strategies assist in
migration planning and help
organizations optimize their Cloud usage
and cost efficiency the average salary
both Cloud Consulting in India is 26
lakhs per annum and in United States of
America the salaries range from hundred
and twenty thousand dollars to 170 000
per annum having discussed the different
roles in cloud computing let's proceed
with the certifications you will need to
become one at the end of the day
certifications will help you get one
step closer in bagging your dream job
with the relevant real-time skills
required simply learn offers a wide
range of online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities in collaboration with
real-time industry experts like IBM and
many more the first one on the list is
Caltech cloud computing bootcamp offered
by simply learn from Caltech in
collaboration with IBM the Caltech cloud
computing bootcamp helps you become an
expert in Azure and AWS this in-depth
cloud computing online bootcamp course
lets you master key architectural all of
this case required to become a cloud
expert this Caltech cloud computing
bootcamp helps you become an expert in
designing planning and scaling cloud
implementations cloud computing course
will help you master the core skills
required to design and apply dynamically
scalable and reliable applications on
Microsoft Azure and AWS for more details
on this course please visit the link in
the description box below the second one
in the list is AWS Cloud architect the
AWS Cloud architect certification course
will make you an expert in Amazon web
services in this program you will become
familiar with AWS architectural
principles and services and learn how to
design and deploy highly scalable and
fault tolerant applications on AWS
Implement AWS security and testing and
become an expert in AWS components such
as S3 and cloud formation the AWS Cloud
architect certification training will
enable you to master the core skills
required for Designing and deploying
dynamically scalable highly available
fault Holden and reliable applications
on top of Cloud platform providers like
AWS you will learn the fundamental of
AWS Cloud platform and become an expert
in understanding AWS terminologies
Concepts benefits and deploying
operations to meet your business
requirements for more details on this
course please visit the link in the
description box below the third one on
the list is cloud architect
certification simply learns Cloud
architect certification course will
build your AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform expertise from the
ground up the cloud program is designed
to make you an expert in Cloud
applications and architecture it will
ensure you to master the core skill sets
required to designing and deploying a
dynamically scalable highly available
fault origin and reliable applications
on these three top Cloud platform
providers for more details on this
course please visit the link in the
description box below and finally we
have the AWS Solutions architect
certification training course the AWS
certification training course is
essential for every aspiring AWS
certified Solutions architect you will
Master AWS architectural principles and
services such as IEM VPC ec2 and EBS and
elevate your career to the cloud and
Beyond with the AWS course the AWS
Solutions architect certification
training course will enable you to
design plan and scale AWS
implementations utilizing over 70 Cloud
Computing Services the AWS training is
aligned with the latest AWS exam
featuring Amazon designated best
practices for more details on this
course please visit the link in the
description box below before we end this
video let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers
[Music]
when I won the Grammy Award back in 2007
I saw that was it that was the highest
point in my life
I eventually made a choice to drive
software development as my full-time job
and this year I changed my domain to
cloud computing simple learn scores help
me make the switch and get a new job
with a 100 salary hike
hey I'm Jorge I live in Georgia USA with
my wife two sons and two dogs
I started off as a video editor and
producer in Venezuela I even started my
own company there
in 2006 I work as one of the producers
and writer for the short music video
Bena Mikasa esta Navidad the video got
me the Latin Grammy Award in the best
video category for the year 2007.
my life was all set I shifted to the
United States with my wife and son in
2008 as a president with special
abilities
the first two years were really hard
there was no work I have to start from
scratch I landed some projects but those
were not enough
to survive I have to make some hard
decisions I have done some software
development in Venezuela
so in 2011 I got a job as a software
developer over the years I fell in love
with my professional
so last year to advance my career I made
another choice to upskill myself with
simple learns cloud computing bootcamp
in association with Caltech ctme the
word is rather than moving towards Cloud
technology and I wanted to have a
professional certification in the scene
the course proved to be very beneficial
I completed the course in June this year
and within three weeks I got hired as a
cloud engineer and my salary is just
doubled I got the job because of the AWS
and Azure technologies that I learned
during the course
do I have it on a full-time ID
professional I have not given up on my
passion for video production
it was hard initially but my work
eventually got me recognition and
acknowledgment since then I have worked
on several short videos and films like
the case against Mr Shepard verified
music in there and many more
my Mantra is never give up always try to
become better and keep your eye on the
price
with that we have come to an end of this
video on cloud computing salaries and
certifications
should you have any queries regarding
any of the information covered in this
session or need an assistance with any
of our courses do let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to reach out to
you shortly until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
thank you